(swooshing)
- [Narrator] Getting word of mouth.
"If you do build a great experience
"customers tell each other about that.
"Word of mouth is very powerful."
Jeff Bezos, billionaire
co-founder of Amazon.com.
If you don't get powerful
word of mouth, you're sunk.
You don't have the big budgets to take out
a Super Bowl commercial or
hire a celebrity spokesperson.
You need people talking about you.
Having a great product
or service isn't enough.
You need to make it easy for
people to talk about you.
Think about how busy your customers are.
They have opportunities every single day
to promote you to their
colleagues and friends.
Every single day.
And they don't, why?
It's not because they don't
love your product or service.
If they don't, then
you need to get to work
on improving your offering.
It's because you don't standout enough.
They forget about you, you're just okay.
But when you stand for
something important,
something people feel connected to,
so that people are proud to be a part of
and you make it easy for them to share
because they only have
to remember one word,
then referrals start to flow.
Make your message difficult,
boring and unremarkable
and nobody will talk about you.
Make your message one word,
powerful and important,
and people will be delighted
to spread your message
at every possible opportunity.
(swooshing)